so let's now dig in more specifically to
just one of the pardons and clemency
grants that Donald Trump did yesterday
so I already kind of given you the big
picture eleven people received different
forms of clemency from Donald Trump
yesterday the the theme is it's elites
pardoning elites it's Trump setting up a
framework of pardoning both Republicans
and Democrats in advance of pardoning
his cronies it is the normalization of
corruption political corruption as that
even really a crime Trump insisting on
Twitter nobody even really knows what
Roger stone did which is of course not
true but it's part of this idea that
political corruption and cronyism and
all the stuff Trump said he would
eliminate as president it actually is
stuff he's not only not eliminating he
thinks should simply be legal now when
it comes to the specific idea of
pardoning former Illinois governor Rod
Blagojevich Donald Trump admits he
doesn't really know Blagojevich but he
did see rod Blagojevich his wife on TV
and that is what gave him information
about the Blagojevich case take a look
at what Donald Trump said yesterday
about that we have commuted the sentence
of Rod Blagojevich he served eight years
in jail it's a long time and I watched
his wife on television I don't know him
very well I've met him a couple of times
he was on for a short while on the
apprentice years ago seems like a very
nice person don't know him but he served
eight years in jail is a long time to go
many people disagree with a sentence
he's a Democrat he's not a Republican so
notice that he says I don't know blue
guy ovitch but I saw his wife on
television so I started looking around
what is it that Rod Blagojevich's wife
has said and done on television that
might interest Donald Trump well it
turns out that patty Blagojevich has
been on Fox News a few times and she
specifically linked Rod Blagojevich's
situation to Donald Trump's saying James
Comey and Robert Muller have perverted
the law against Donald Trump just like
they perverted the law against my
husband rod Blagojevich the following
month in
another Fox News appearance patty
Blagojevich said the same people who
went after her husband are going after
Donald Trump now defending Donald Trump
against investigation saying this very
popular Republican talking point they
meaning investigators Democrats who
knows are trying to undo elections and
play politics instead of doing what
they're supposed to do supportive of
Donald Trump during these appearances
check out this clip have you heard any
more about the potential for a pardon
from the president I haven't heard
anything at all I you know we are so
grateful for the president you didn't be
thinking about us in that respect he's
given our family a tremendous amount of
Hope and you know we're confident that
the president's gonna do what he thinks
is right regarding that so I mean we are
you know we say our prayers every night
and hopefully look for the chid the day
that my husband gets home you know this
whole thing that this happening this
weekend is just so familiar to me you
know I can't believe these people are at
it again you know they use whether it's
using false information to obtain you
know warrants or turning you know
trusted advisors and despised against
you against you it's it's like almost
like I'm reliving it all over again when
you talk about this weekend you talk
about Paul Manafort I'm just talking
no no I'm talking about like this the
latest revelations about how the FISA
Court and how that they used slander
that was essentially opposition research
slander against the president to you
know to spy on him so it makes no sense
Patti Blagojevich's they're trying to
use some of the debunked Trump talking
points about the Russia probe using them
in articulately but the idea is clear
defend Trump while saying we have
suffered at the same hands and this
worked very very well
Trump acknowledges he saw patty
Blagojevich on TV and now he's pardoning
rod Blagojevich if you want pardons or
commuted sentences you know what to do
bad mouth Comey and Muller while
defending Donald Trump and Trump will do
anything you want and in the
meantime we've also learned that the
construction company owner that Donald
Trump pardoned a guy named Paul Pogue
his son and daughter-in-law donated
$200,000 to Donald Trump's campaign
since August of last year
once again it's more of the same Trump
said he would get corruption out Trump
has actually done more to normalize
corruption than any recent president and
to think about it another way if you
want to zoom out and look at what's
going on here this is another one of the
ways in which Mitch McConnell and other
Republican senators are enabling all of
this they ignored and actually blocked
relevant testimony and evidence from the
impeachment trial which they knew they
were going to be voting for an acquittal
for Trump at the end of from the
beginning they are now looking the other
way as Donald Trump is laying the
groundwork to normalize corruption to
start pardoning his associates and this
is very similar to something there's
elements of this that are similar about
how Saddam Hussein came to power in Iraq
you know we often wonder here in the
United States how does the country just
lose control and go from being a
relatively secular and advanced country
developed country like Iraq into being
taken over by someone like Haddam Saddam
Hussein how does it happen it could
never happen here well it's been
described actually how Saddam came to
power in Iraq and it was an Iraq that
was previously quite modern quite
moderate in many ways and you create
what is sometimes called a republic of
fear this is actually described in a
book by Kenan Makia Kanaan Makia later
lobbied for the u.s. to invade Iraq and
has not been right on anything but very
interestingly describing sort of the
atmosphere in Iraq in the lead-up to
Saddam Hussein taking over and the idea
is this Republic of fear you pardon some
people and then you essentially own them
you get away with manipulating the
justice system and courts and you create
a situation where people who you appear
to be on the same side as fear you
because they worried you might turn on
them people who are on opposite sides of
fear you because they see that you are
running
rampant and flouting all of the norms
and checks and balances and and all of
the infrastructure that is supposed to
prevent exactly this type of despotic
behavior and then all of a sudden you
get a situation where you might take
someone that you previously were
praising and you very publicly point to
them as an example of what's wrong you
put them in front of the public and say
this person did all of these bad things
and then everybody who you've been
protecting all of a sudden starts to
panic Trump was protecting me before but
is this the end I'd better start turning
on the people around me I'd better
pledge my loyalty to Trump louder than
anybody else and I'll do whatever he
wants because I've got to stay on Donald
Trump's good side this sort of dynamic
very similar to what was going on in the
increasingly corrupt Iraq that was
ultimately under the power of Saddam
Hussein doesn't mean everything is the
same about the u.s. and 2020 and Iraq
decades ago but an interesting crossover
there and this is all Trump normalizing
the exact type of corruption that he
said so many times he was going to be
the guy to get rid of let me know what
you think about the pardons we will take
a quick break and be back after this
with much much more I want to give a
quick shout out to one of our sponsors
VIN Chara watches they're giving my
audience 15% off your entire order when
you go to david pakman.com slash watch
maybe you don't usually wear a watch and
you've been thinking about looking for
one to elevate your look or you've been
thinking about replacing the one you
have
check out Vin Charo it's an American
company all of their watches are built
in small batches from high-end materials
they look amazing and they look like
something you'd spend a lot of money on
but ever even chero watch ranges from a
hundred and fifty to three hundred
dollars I went on their website and
picked out the Kyros in white and silver
really love the look the combination of
the white face and the beige band really
love this one they also sent me the
Kairos limited release gold reserve set
totally different style this one would
make a fantastic gift for a couple
people I can think of in my family any
time you see me wear
wearing a watch on the show I'm wearing
Aven Chara watch go through their
collection I know you'll find something
you like and you'll get 15% off when you
go to david pakman.com slash watch